everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem valid parentheses
string we've solved a few parentheses
related problems on this channel but
this is a pretty unique one so we're
given a string s and it could contain
three types of characters a left
parenthesis a right parenthesis and a
wild card character and the wild card
character could
be a three possibilities it could be an
empty string which is the simplest right
so basically in that case we would
ignore the wild card it could be a right
parenthesis or it could be a left
parenthesis so
each time we reach a wild card
in terms of a decision tree we really
have three branches right we have three
different things we could consider it
could be a space it could be a left
parenthesis it could be a right
parenthesis so already we're kind of
getting the intuition of how to solve
this problem or at least enumerate all
possibilities our goal is to determine
if the given string could be valid if
it's possible we return true if it's
impossible we return false and you can
go over this to understand what makes
parentheses valid and invalid the main
thing is as you scan through a string
suppose this one what has to really
happen is that every left parenthesis
has to have a matching right parenthesis
and the matching right parenthesis has
to come after the left parentheses and
the natural order for it is kind of like
first in first out so you can see we
have a left parenthesis then we have
another left parenthesis then we have a
right parenthesis and this right
parenthesis matches this one okay then
we have another left parenthesis then we
have a right parenthesis this matches
the most recent one and then we have
another right parentheses and this
matches this one but suppose we had a
slightly different string maybe we have
three right parentheses in a row this
would be invalid and you can see why
these two match each other great this
one matches this one great but the right
parentheses then comes before the left
parenthesis we can't have that and this
is one way to understand that but the
easiest way to know that we have an
invalid parenthesis combination is that
at any given point of the string the
number of left parentheses that we have
can never be less than the number of
right parentheses and you can see that
that happens here right we have two left
parentheses then we have three right
parentheses and we are never going to be
able to recover from this because at one
point in time we had more right
parentheses than we had left it doesn't
matter if we get more left parentheses
we cannot recover from this ever and
that's how you know it's invalid let's
take a very simple input string and then
determine if this is valid or not and we
can tell that it is how would it be
valid if the wild card was empty and it
would look like this right just a left
and a right parenthesis but how can we
do that uh brute force and we would we
could possibly have more complex strings
how could we determine that well the
brute force is going to be a decision
tree because if we weren't given any
wild cards we have a very simple
algorithm just to scan through the
parentheses to know if they were valid
or not just like i talked about but with
wild cards there's lots of possibilities
we're going to go through each character
in the string and have a decision tree
so first character we see is a left
parenthesis that's perfectly fine and
then we get to the wild card right when
you get to a wild card that's when you
actually need to branch we don't need to
just branch when we get to a regular
parenthesis because that's already
determined it could be another left
parenthesis it could be a space or it
could be a right parenthesis
and then we're going to get to the third
character uh but we have to do that
third character it's already determined
it's a right parenthesis but we have to
do it for all three of our branches now
so you can kind of see if we had a lot
of wild cards uh this decision tree
would get very big but let's just finish
it up real quick so here we'll have a
right parenthesis here we'll have a
right parentheses here we'll have a
right parenthesis so among all three of
these combinations you can see that this
is invalid because it has two open it
has two left one right that's invalid
this one you can see is also invalid it
has one left and then two right but the
middle one you can see it is valid it
has a left a space and then a right and
the way we could do this problem
recursively the decision tree portion is
kind of simple we would make three
recursive calls every time
we got to a wild card but to determine
if it was valid or not one we would keep
track of how many left parentheses we
had how many open left parentheses we
had at this point we had one open
if we're just considering the middle
branch here we also had a one open and
then by the end of it we had zero open
zero left open parenthesis by the end we
should have exactly zero because they
should all match each other and the
number of left open should never be
negative for example if we started like
this right if we started with a right
parenthesis that's automatically invalid
okay so that's the recursive solution
and you can actually add dynamic
programming and by dynamic programming i
mean memoization that's the easier way
to do it to this recursive solution and
i will actually link the code to that in
the description if you want to take a
look uh the overall time complexity of
first of all the brute force solution is
in the worst case going to be a 3 to the
power of n because that's how many
branches we have n is going to be the
size of the string because that's going
to be the height of this decision tree
but when you add memoization to this the
overall time complexity actually becomes
n cubed and the way we would do that is
by caching and we would cache uh with
two parameters one would be i which is
the index of the position that we're at
and the other parameter would be uh the
number of left open parentheses at any
given point uh in the string that we're
at now a caching with two different
parameters like this will cause us to
have a two-dimensional matrix uh the
size of that matrix is going to be n
squared but to calculate each value in
that matrix would would take big o of n
time complexity that's how i'm getting n
cubed from but i don't expect you to
understand all of this if you want to
understand it a bit more you can look at
the code that i'll have in the
description but there's actually an even
more efficient way to solve this problem
and that is the greedy solution and it's
very difficult to come up with now even
if you can't come up with the greedy
solution by yourself it might still
occur to you in a real interview that
maybe there's some kind of trick to this
problem that if only you could figure it
out you would be able to solve this
problem in linear time is there a trick
like that well hopefully in a real
interview your interviewer would give
you a hint for that but let's see how we
could maybe come up with it ourselves we
know that one variable is going to be a
mandatory for us and i'm going to call
it left it's going to be the number of
left open parentheses we have and when
we reach the first character it's a left
open parenthesis initially our total is
going to be zero but after seeing the
left open parenthesis we increment it by
one now we have one left open
parenthesis and that would be very easy
uh suppose we didn't have the wild card
then we would have a right parenthesis
and we would do the exact opposite we'd
say okay left uh open parenthesis has
been decremented by one so now we're
back to zero left open parenthesis and
that makes sense but wild cards create
multiple possibilities and three exactly
right one the simplest would be to
ignore this right if we ignore it okay
we're still left with one open
parenthesis that's the simplest but it
could there could be multiple
possibilities right and we need to
consider all possibilities if we want to
be sure that we can determine if this is
possibly valid or not possibly valid we
do have to consider every possibility so
another possibility is this wild card
could be a
left open parenthesis if that's the case
we would take our left and actually
increment it by one to make it two but
another possibility is that this a wild
card could be a right parenthesis and in
that case we would take this and then
decrement it by one see how this wild
card is creating some divergence for us
we can't maintain all possibilities in a
single variable like we could before so
this is kind of a hint to you that maybe
we need two variables let's go to the
third character before we actually
create those two variables now we have a
right parenthesis now what are we gonna
do well with right parentheses we're
gonna decrement our left count but now
we have to decrement two variables so
this would become one and then this
would become zero what do these actually
represent the reason we have two in the
first place is from the wild card
basically these are gonna represent the
i'm gonna call it the left max and the
left min and what that means is what's
the
maximum left open left parenthesis we
could have and what's the minimum open
left parenthesis we could have depending
on how we choose our wild card okay now
let's go to another character and again
we have a wild card now let me explain
to you what these two variables are
supposed to represent they're supposed
to represent the range of possibilities
we could have zero left open parentheses
or we could have one left open
parentheses depending on how we chose
the first wild card but now we have a
second wildcard now if we made this a
left open parenthesis that would mean
it's possible for us to have two left
open parentheses so we would update our
left max in that case but if we made it
a closing parenthesis then we would want
to update our minimum because this is
supposed to represent all possibilities
so let's do exactly that if
let's increment our left max to be 2
then let's decrement our left min to be
negative one but hold on for a second
this isn't just the range of
possibilities this should also be the
valid range of possibilities we should
never have our left min become negative
because that would imply that the
choices we made caused our left min to
be negative and we know that's invalid
so we're never going to allow our left
min to become negative if it ever does
become negative we're going to reset it
back to b0 so now you can see that these
are the range of possibilities between
zero and two and now we're just going to
continue through the rest of the array
we're going to get a left open
parenthesis which uh we're going to
increment both of our variables so this
is going to be 1 this is going to be a 3
and then we're going to get a closing
parenthesis so this is going to be
decremented down to 0. this is going to
be decremented down to 2. and now how do
we know if we can return true or false
is this valid or is it not valid well we
know it's balanced if the left open
parenthesis count is zero so does zero
fall in between our range right now it
does because our left min is exactly
zero so that's how you know we can
return true if our left min is equal to
zero and before we get into the code i
just want to show you another way that
our solution could have been invalid uh
suppose you know our string had two uh
closing parentheses and then two open of
course our left min is never going to be
uh negative because uh if it becomes
negative we reset it back to zero but if
our left max does become negative uh in
this case it'll be negative two uh from
this uh at this after we've seen these
two that's how you know we can return
false because it'll never be valid we'll
never recover from this because if the
maximum number of left open parentheses
we could have is negative that means
there's no choices we could possibly do
to make this valid okay so before we get
into the code as you could tell from
this algorithm we don't even need any
extra space so the space complexity is
bigger of zero and we only need to scan
through the string once so the time
complexity is big o of n so now let's
code it up okay so now let's code it up
and like i said we're gonna have two
variables left min and left max
initially they're both gonna be a zero
and then we're just going to go through
every single character in the string if
we get a open parenthesis a left open
parenthesis we're going to increment
both of our variables so leftmin and
leftmax are going to be incremented by
one because here we don't really have
any choices we have to increment the
count by one and in the opposite case
where we do have a closing parenthesis
we also don't have a choice so i'm going
to copy and paste this but in that case
we're going to be decrementing the count
by one for each of them uh and the else
case is when we have a wild card we
don't have to specify that character and
this is the part where we do have a
choice so i'll copy and paste again but
with the left min we're going to
decrement that count in the case that we
have a closing parenthesis and in the
case that we choose the wild card to be
an open parenthesis we're going to
increment the left max by 1. but
remember if the left max ever is
negative that means it's impossible for
our parentheses to be valid so in that
case we're just going to immediately
return false but in the similar case
where our left min is negative we're not
necessarily going to return false
because that would mean our left max is
not negative so it technically is
possible for the string to still be
valid we don't want to continue assuming
that our string up until this point is
invalid so we're going to reset it back
to zero and if
this part is unclear and i don't expect
it to be too clear because it's actually
complicated to understand this is the
string that i would kind of run the code
on and this is the example i would
really try to understand if you don't
get this part this string is impossible
to make valid no matter what we choose
for the wild card but if you don't
include this if statement in your code
you'll end up returning true for this
when you should be returning false
that's kind of what i'll leave it at but
other than that once we exit the loop we
will return true if the left min is
equal to zero if it's not equal to zero
then we return false now let's run the
code to make sure that it works and as
you can see on the left yes it does and
it's pretty efficient so i really hope
that this was helpful if it was please
like and subscribe it really supports
the channel a lot consider checking out
my patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching